voici l'est de la rue rachel version
était 2020 voici la nouvelle rue laurier
est la rue christophe colomb sur presque
toute sa longueur est aussi plusieurs
tronçons de la rue beaubien
quatre exemples parmi tant d'autres plus
que jamais au cours des prochains mois
automobilistes vélos et piétons devront
se partager les rues de montréal
dans une ville comme montréal 80% des
gens nombreux qu on a besoin de sortir
dehors on le sait on le vit donc l'idée
était de créer de l'espace
cette carte montre une partie des 900 km
de voies cyclables déjà existante sur
l'île ajoutez-y au moins pour le temps
de la pandémie
ses quelques 300 kilomètres
supplémentaires de corridas aménagé pour
vélos piétons
ça fait plus de mille kilomètres pour
rouler et les cyclistes sont heureux
comme des poissons dans l'eau ça fait
plus de ce passe comme ça ceux qui
souhaitent leur famille puis avec les
enfants quand ils sont dans une fois on
peut le dépasser par l'autre voix
s'inquiètent des risques face à face
peut-être que ça va encourager les
automobilistes à prendre leur vélo qui
sait pas ce que ça vous donne le goût de
troquer votre voiture pour un vélo mais
si je pouvais travailler le mauvais le
oui lèverait en ville malgré les débuts
du déconfinement les automobilistes sont
encore peu nombreux mais il ne faudrait
pas qu'il y en ait trop il faut
s'adapter faut rester sage et s'adapte à
des geôliers des travaux ne sont pas
achevés
on est en train d'en avant et donc midi
il y à aussi l'opinion des résidents
pour qui ces espaces sont destinés
beaucoup sont bien contents
car moi je sens ça devient très simple
même pour aller faire un minime course
mais ça va me laisser de latitude pour
voyager en europe à deux festivals et
rothen grand événement fait chausser
grande beune dit que la ville crée des
espaces où est ce que les montréalais
vont pouvoir se retrouver mais quelques
uns sont frustrés comme bible qui
habitent sur le plateau et qui a porté
plainte à la ville
quand je me promène le jour j'ai testé
sur papineau au point de laurier a
besoin de la stationner sur les rues
adjacentes nommé depuis c'est un fermage
fête au château et le pôle du que
voulez-vous des japonais devant chez lui
on rencontre quelques commerçants
frustré il y a de la grogne sur laurier
est
c'est ce qu'on a toujours par les gens
vont venir une fois ils vont se rendre
compte bien se passer pour moi de se
garer tandis que les livraisons c'est
pour tous les commerçants
moi je déplore qu'il n'y ait pas eu de
consultation même pas un petit mot dans
la porte
la ville ne peut pas dire combien de
places de stationnement ont été retirés
mais il est vrai que ce gars est sur
bien des artères commerciales est devenu
difficile souvent impossible ce que ses
patrons quelque part il faut trouver de
l'espace à quelque part mais avec une
réduction de la circulation
on pense trouver le bon équilibre avec
les sd sic et il n'y a pas de modèle
unique qui est exporté d'une artère
commerciale alors on trouve le bon mix
pour chaque artère ce n'était en tout
cas pas le bon mixte dans la petite
italie où la ville proposait de fermer
le boulevard saint laurent aux voitures
le propriétaire de la célèbre fruiterie
milano a même embauché une avocate avec
d'autres commerçants la ville à reculer
l'euro pas de changement sur saint
laurent dans la petite italie parce que
on ne pas trouver un scénario encore
qu'ils convainquent étonnement mais on y
travaille encore de nombreux
propriétaires de bars ou des restaurants
sont quant à eux bien content
mais pour pour l'essayer puis c'est un
une des mesures qui peut nous aider
certainement pour passer au travers la
crise l'administration plantes assure
que toutes les installations mises sur
pied en s'étendent coronavirus sont
temporaires ici jean sébastien cloutier
radio canada montréal